You don't drink coffee?
No.
I don't trust anybody
who doesn't drink coffee.
Yeah, I don’t-
This interview is over.
(laughs)
My name is Nick Barili,
and I'm traveling the country
to sit down with some
of the biggest Latinx artists
in places that have
meanting to them
and help tell their stories.
This was probably the
place I grew most.
This whole movement
is to make sure
that we do learn our history.
This is baile folklórico.
My family was under
five different flags
without ever moving.
I'm ninth generation American.
I never crossed a border.
The border crossed us.
When people go “go home,”
we are home.
This is home.
This is the only way that you're
going to break through
as a new show or a movie
is through innovation,
and the only way innovation
happens is by diversity.
And so you can't keep going
back to that same talent pool
because you're going
to get the same movie.
You're never too old to learn.
You're never too old
to finish something or to
go back and do something.
I'm going to do this.
I can do this.
I did it, you know?